The joe rogan experience.
All right.
We're live ladies and gentlemen
with a whole new set up a yeah.
Yeah.
When they listen ma'am,
I'm very irresponsible.
You're not going to be really cool is
when we get something right back here.
That's the next step.
We're trying to figure out
what to put right back there.
Most likely is going to be a green screen
cause I'm looking at this right now.
I'm like how dope would it be if
we were in fucking space right now?
Yeah.
[inaudible]
so Adderall give you clarity.
That's hilarious.
Cause my kids are trying to get me off it.
Why you're trying to get math.
My fucking kids like that.
I put through Rehab,
give me shit about my fucking
hair all tell me it's like no,
it's not like I've never
done math except for,
you know,
two times guys married to Tom Arnold.
But aside from that,
you know I've never,
I would never get into math.
It would be very strange if one day it
was proven that we are really living in
some sort of self created reality.
It would be like a really traumatizing
for a lot of people that have fucked it
up.
You'd be like,
this is what I made.
But it's like,
remember when you were in school and like
there was a project and you had to use
your hand and make a Turkey
and you put your hand down.
He drew around and then you know,
everybody did their own little Turkey
painted it and then the teacher would put
him up in the,
and I'll look at them and some people's,
Turkey's looked like dog shit.
I looked,
I didn't know what the
fuck a Turkey looked like.
They didn't even know how
to draw around their hand.
Like everything was a disaster.
And other people that beautiful darkies
well your life is a work of art.
Your,
your life is like a hand Turkey
that you make in grade school.
It's,
you could do whatever
you want with that thing.
You can make it super dope.
Yeah.
You know you can,
you can make it so it looks really cool
if you put the effort and time into it.
If you really focus on it.
John Travolta met a single handedly,
made more men gay just from this music
and from singing and dancing and getting
people to dance.
He probably personally,
it was probably his total overall goal,
which is to say nothing
of his bath house work.
Do you mask your farts when you
should shit in a public restroom?
No.
Let it out.
You gotta do what you were going
to hold up to the left girl.
An idiot.
Jesus Christ.
You have it on your phone.
I love girl farts.
Yeah.
40 year old man.
He's got it on his phone.
Jesus Christ.
Oh yeah.
Anybody who says it doesn't
go in your asshole shut it.
He's clearly looking at
that and just being like,
yeah,
you fucking,
it's well,
you know it doesn't always go in.
Sometimes it just hits the taint.
Sometimes it's just the that would hurt.
That would hurt.
You got a good grip on the upper deck
and it doesn't actually get in the
asshole.
He's just calling the lit up,
pulling the lit up on the
macaroni and cheese container.
Just get the steam out.
Yeah,
just Tupperware in that motherfucker.
But sometimes it goes
in the asshole freakiest
thing is you know how to rope off
everything at a Times Square when uh,
when the ball is going
to drop or whatever.
Yeah.
And there's a certain time you
can't go past the barricades.
One night I was there and
the guy said,
well you remember the
Church of Scientology?
And I said,
yeah,
and he let me in through the barricade.
Real Story.
Dude,
real story.
He probably just wanted to fuck you
[inaudible] handsome guy.
But that's what they told me.
So like that would probably be
like 7% or something like that.
If I was,
I was super,
super lean but not doing compared to
these guys with these guys are doing,
I was,
I was working out with these guys are
doing is like getting real close to death
while keeping giant muscles.
It's fucking madness.
Like this is the nuttiest
fucking sport of all time.
Yeah.
It's performance art.
This duck,
I will rip your Dick
[inaudible] ass doors.
Those bank fault ass doors of his
shit looks like charge our bags.
My grandmother like Moans,
like she's,
she's hurt so bad.
She can't move.
She had an aneurysm 12 years ago,
so she's just lying in bed like that.
Hello.
Here is a man.
She was in just paying the one time.
She does.
She's done from the aneurism on.
They gave her 72 hours to live.
She lived for 12 years.
Yeah,
and it wasn't a good 12 years.
It wasn't a good 12 years,
but see,
your grandfather was getting zero action.
I'd probably do whatever you want it.
This is exactly what I was saying earlier.
GRANDPA's coming in.
You can hide the fucking canola eas,
but you're not high net fucking bloom.
Hey,
she's going to be hairy guy.
That fucking God goes,
oh,
she got a big fucking juicy guy
who she's saying at the end of it,
that's when you know you're done.
When you hit the Gaga.
Good.
On this broad,
what I fucking do,
you should say of her,
my brother,
I don't know if she's moaning
because of the aneurism.
Gogo Kellogg
from Kellogg cereal.
Right.
He had a thing.
He was very,
you ever see that?
People who masturbate you
gotta thing about that.
I mean the whole thing
with the corn flakes,
the reason corn flakes were invented
was to stop boys from masturbation.
How was it?
How was the idea behind that?
We do that explained
this to us before then.
The idea is that spicy foods excite
the sensibilities and so if you eat
something that tastes interesting,
you're going to want to come.
So they,
they embed and also Graham crackers.
Graham was another,
these big ante masturbation
evangelizers so invent these really
intentionally bland foods.
They like to keep the teenage boys from
jerking off so that when they finger,
they're assholes.
They immediately calm.
Exactly
veal.
Keep them in the dark.
Oh yeah,
cow could milk itself.
That would be bad.
And she goes,
Oh,
I'm not the problem with money anymore.
Your father's the one who
spends all the money now.
And then she pointed my,
Dan goes,
tell him,
tell him what you spend your money on.
And I've already clicked
what this won't be.
And I've gone,
oh wait,
look,
I want to know.
I don't want to know.
And then it goes,
your father gets prostitutes
and I've gone,
oh,
just shut up.
Both of your police and she's gone
yet every Wednesday your father,
before he goes to play lawn bowls goes
off and gets himself a prostitute.
And then my dad went,
not every Wednesday.
Do you have a catch phrase when you hunt,
when you hit one?
I need one.
Well,
yes.
Blam Blam we eating ham.
I'm not sure if he's going to answer.
Yeah,
you're on the radio.
You're live on the podcast.
Fucking doors over there.
That's all I love.
Say I love you.
I love you man.
We love you too,
man.
No,
that's how you impregnate.
The Sun would come
up a black hole.
We don't know what to
do about a black hole.
We can get an infinite amount
of Dunkin's to come in it.
Well,
it's,
you know,
mass broken down to the smallest,
right?
It's not going to stop an
infinite amount of come.
Trust me,
there's a whole other universe inside.
They're still not big enough
for infinite amounts of calm.
Sorry.
The black hole is like,
what the fuck?
So
this is one of the things,
especially talking to college
students that I love bringing up,
which is that,
and I'm the first to a minute,
like I have no fucking
clue what I'm doing.
99% of the time,
especially when I got started,
I still don't know.
And I've,
I've come to realize like,
and I've got,
I've got,
I've been lucky enough to meet
some pretty like successful,
impressive people.
But like you dig under the surface,
we're all just hacking it.
Like we're all just expertise,
experience,
those things all help.
But like every one of
us is a fallible human,
all the and rules and status quo we know
were created by other fallible humans.
Yeah.
And there's no reason not
to look at that and go,
Huh,
does it have to be that way?
Or why is it that way?
And if the reason why is,
well that's the way it is.
Well that's a terrible reason,
you know?
And,
and when you see the world
as being that hackable,
so to speak,
like you start to realize,
all right,
well let's just,
let's actually question stuff.
Tell,
did you see a special roadwork?
I heard it's awesome.
So funny.
But he,
um,
I was sitting at the table with my dissing
rounds of venture female comics and
we were like eating dessert.
It was like a really like,
sad moment.
He just walks up.
We're like,
hey Dave.
He's like,
oh,
what are you guys having
no boyfriend mode?
Tell him what does that tell a story?
We're all from about keep Kimbo slice.
Kimbo slice on ultimate fighter.
Yeah.
When you were guys were doing that,
they didn't even show this on there.
So this guy,
I'm not going to mention
his name on the show.
He lost and you can drink all that
alcohol you want in the house.
And there's only,
at the time there's only four of us left,
still fighting and one of
the other guys is hammered.
Hammered.
He's lost,
right.
Hammered,
wasted.
All of a sudden this guy gets super racist
in the house and there's all bunch of
black guys in the house.
I'm sleeping.
And I thought it was a dream.
Kimbo slice and,
uh,
Marcus Jones and this and this
d'amico and this demicco Rogers,
uh,
comes in my room.
They go,
Yo,
shop,
get up,
dog.
Get up man.
I'm like,
Huh,
why are there three large
black guys run my bed?
Kim Goes,
Yo man,
this dude's down there
talking about our people.
We're about to jack him up.
I literally,
I thought I was in the gym.
I go,
excuse me,
it's talking about our people dog.
Let's go eff this dude up and like,
listen,
uh,
you guys realize I said,
I'm,
I'm told I'm not down with the race thing.
I'm totally down to fuck this dude up.
But you realize I'm not black,
right.
Kim Goes,
you ain't
no bad.
He goes,
damn,
that's crazy.
Turn around and leave.
And I hear that's why a lot shop,
you can't tell what the hell he is.
I go eight Kimbo that's racist dog,
Ypo.
Just cause I'm athletic and
can file you gotta be black.
He goes,
you could be and cute
I guess.
But here's the other thing.
I mean,
I,
I don't even know if the
word is trick and I'll,
I mean I totally fell for him.
The shit out of you.
I feel like,
I guess it is trek,
but it's also once he was like,
why would I question that in my life?
No one's ever lied about where
they went to school that I knew of.
Right.
These are not lies that in society
we're told to look out for.
It'd be one like everyone's like,
does he have another family?
I wouldn't even think
about like your school.
Like who cares?
It's like lying about your blood type.
Disruption in a competitive
market is actually very,
very enticing to the,
to the second and third tier players
because they don't have an advantage.
There are too small to
compete against the big guys.
But if they see this
disruptive technology,
I think,
well maybe if I hit your ride on
that I'm going to overtake everybody.
Um,
and you know,
I can be the blockbuster
or it can be the Netflix.
I can be the tower records
or I can be the iTunes.
And we've seen this happen in
technology racist before of course,
but I meant like when you're not
doing this and you said five hours,
five hours maybe.
Is that because you all juiced
up with nicotine all the time?
I think cause I'm old and my prostate
tells me it's time to get up.
I take a leak five hours and you're good.
Um,
if I'm lucky,
you know,
get some palm palm juice.
Have you tried some of
those pills that help?
What is this doctor Oz who gives a shit?
It's like we were just watching
heavy metal and there's like a,
a Caribou carcass here.
It's like,
have you ever thought of
like who gives a shit?
It's part of getting
old guys get used to it.
Get used to it.
Let's say that
they somehow cooptive and we sell that.
Right?
Tony also replace Alex Jones.
He's waiting.
He's in Austin,
Texas.
You say you're the number one,
but I've got the statistics.
I've got the documents right
here and show you're a liar.
Jank you're a new world order puppet.
He seems like he's out there
working for the people.
He's not working for the
people who went for MSNBC.
Ladies and gentlemen,
you don't get to Msnbc unless you
sell your soul to David Ike's.
Reptilians I you see I use a
prop on my first open mic and uh,
I didn't realize it was racist.
I'm just race.
What was it?
A black like join the cross burning.
I mean as a monkey with a fucking
jockey outfit on and a basketball,
his hat on backwards with
a boombox and his shoulder.
I had no idea
it was a punching.
None.
Picking cotton in blackface
chained to a plantation stare.
It was open Mike Nights.
Sorry.
Is robbing a white man.
Hey Batman book,
Fat Albert's friend with
the hat over his face open.
Dabu Hey,
no dues.
Racist.
I'm sorry.
What were you saying?
I've had sex.
Why life sold after the woman left
because he thought I was rational.
You thought it was rational?
No,
cause I remember she was like
scratching this area of her body.
When she left.
I was like freaked out so hard.
But I went into my bathroom,
I started Lysol hauling my legs
like shape and then dish soap.
And then Lysaght and the next day I,
speaking of 12 step meetings,
I went to my first and only
sex addicts anonymous meeting.
I was just like,
something's got to change.
To look at your face was awesome,
but you know,
there's no,
there's very little,
well,
the way for you to convince yourself that
you're just like a young man swinging
around,
having a good time,
engaging in the regular sexuality of all
human beings when you're spraying Lysol
on here.
And so now,
you know,
it's still use faggot in the column.
I'm not one of those uh,
gay rights activists who,
you know,
when David Spade or Jonah Hill or Alec
Baldwin uses Faggot like falls down and
screams and yells and
calls for their heads.
I've actually,
you know,
I defended David well a million years
ago from glad when they were after him.
I think Louis C K does it a
hilarious things with faggot.
So I don't think that it's not a hate
word anymore if you can't let straight
people use it when the case,
when the,
their intent is clearly not hateful.
And so I feel like it shouldn't
be a problem for people
to use the t word tranny
in a non hateful context.
But so many trans people are so
invested right now politically in uh,
in stopping its usage at all ever.
And uh,
you know,
in deference to their
delicate sensibilities
stopped Ari Shaffir has so
many stories about China.
We talked about so many other things
besides his stories about China,
which is how we have to keep going.
So you have bout to tell
some crazy noodle story.
So they had these noodles is
treat noodles you can get,
I was advised the first day,
like you don't want those
and show them this video.
What they would do is they
would go to the sewer,
they would take raw sewage out of the
sewer and then boil it down the way they'd
make wax hash wax,
they'd boil off the sewage and whatever
was left that's cooking oil that they
would use.
It's super fucking harmful.
And then sell to like a lot
of the street noodle guys.
Yeah.
That face is what I made that same face.
They were cooking with sewer oil,
Bro,
I think we've been parasitized by an
astonishing farm of political correctness.
I mean what does Pressa ties
lighten there like a parasite that,
oh right.
So in the same way that I like that word
that viruses can enter your body virus,
viruses of the Mike and
also take over your,
I mean religion is an example of a Mima
plex form of some people would be upset
by what I'm saying,
but a form of parasite that
kind of rewires your thinking.
And so political correctness is a,
an astonishing form of parasitic thinking
where everything is viewed through the
lens of I should not offend anyone.
And so common sense and just reason goes
out the window in the pursuit of non
offense.
This is not a subject I'm really into,
but there is a woman,
this German woman who does shit porn where
people shit on her and she's like the
queen of Shit Porn.
Don't ask me how I know that somebody
posted it on my message board and I
followed a fucking all over link hole.
I went from link to link to link to,
I got to her site and
watch some of her videos.
Your side.
Good egg.com.
Uh,
I feel like,
um,
if you tell me in the
past what's the core age,
what's the opposite of courage?
I want to say cowardness because either
you tough enough to challenge and to
fight or to or in their new
car and then you chicken out.
So that's in the past was like the,
the,
the opposite of,
of,
of courage is very high to
measure this in those days.
And I believe the opposite
of college should they,
is conformity.
You know,
his people get conformed.
Oh,
I,
I don't like my wife
the way I used to like,
but I'm never going to divorce because
I'm afraid to lose my house or the
situation is so established
so I'm going to keep,
so I don't like this job but I got to
keep here because better than he is.
So [inaudible] not the hands of the few.
If you get caught on that
kind of compromise to,
to maintain because you
were you afraid to risk,
that's keep you like one
step behind from you,
follow your heart,
follow your ambition.
So that's kind of pretty much where keep
you from be at your best because if you
willing to sacrifice,
if you're willing to,
to broke new new challenges.
If you really chew you in
the stage of liveliness and,
and excitement and unpredictability,
who make you feel like you're in heaven
even though her neck will fuck though
she was determined to do nominate people
shit like go across and
like go across the track too fast.
Right.
And once I see she had a 64 Chevy,
they used to bounce and
she loved like old music.
So we're not just bouncing,
listen to BB king and
she gonna beat the train.
That bitch hit that first
tracking and net went back.
She's like come and muscles to slap
the shit out of her knee and then went
through the stern way.
Oh we know I had to jump out to sea in
Hola Nica washy drive across the track.
So you pull out your pitches,
hit me too hard.
Muscles like miss the train was coming.
Oh my God,
you bitches.
Sorry.
What's weird when anybody PR like when
a guy is like working in an angle and
trying really hard to like
position himself as better
than he positioned himself
as being like different
than every other guy.
Right.
I'm,
you know,
there's a lot of guys out there
to doing really negative things.
Like I read this one guy's
fucking Twitter page of the day.
It was amazing.
It was just like,
he's,
he might be the ultimate White Knight.
I don't want to give out his Twitter page.
Yeah.
But he,
he might be like the
greatest I if I met him,
he probably has almost no blood in his
veins is blood sugar is probably zero.
He'd probably faints all day long.
It was so weak.
But one of the things he said is he said,
all,
he said,
although I still practice feminists,
I still practice feminism.
I no longer,
um,
associate I no longer,
well,
what'd he say?
Advertise myself as a feminist because
I feel like it's up to women to decide
whether or not I'm doing
feminism correctly.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
So I'll still practice feminism,
but I will no longer advertise
myself as a feminist.
Jesus Christ.
That's a,
I actually don't even know
what to say about that.
Male feminism is a very strange thing,
but we would sit up there all night.
It would be me,
Norton,
mainly Keith and Patrice.
Just Smith.
Billie birther,
fucking Billy comes into the seller,
right?
And she says,
I'm going to the world series.
It's when the mets were
playing the in the world share.
He's a subway.
He goes,
I'm going to the game.
We go,
how the fuck?
How do you get tickets?
He goes,
wow,
these dudes hired me to do a show under
a bus on the way and are given and right
when he said that,
everybody's eyes lit up.
We're fucking
we.
We did shit like this.
You guys are a good crowd.
And off the bus we beat him to
sweat was pouring down Billy's head.
He didn't do it.
He gave the Gig away.
He didn't do it again because
we beat them down so hard.
It just fucking animals.
I tell him,
my daughter,
a couple of,
I made me two months ago about a,
there's an old Spanish proverb that says,
Whoa,
um,
habits begin is cobwebs
and end up as chains.
Way Easier to break in the
beginning than later off.
Right.
Way To put it.
It's a great way to put it.
Wow.
And uh,
anyway,
she just,
she just brought this up,
uh,
you know,
um,
that we were talking about
someone she knew and,
and something that she didn't
like that they did and she said,
yeah,
but they're still pretty
much in the cob web phase,
so they can probably
still change it at him.
Was like,
well,
I even,
I didn't remember.
She's like,
Oh yeah,
the cob webs and change things.
Like she really sunk
in her and she's like,
yeah,
five societaly.
We're so resistant to looking at mental
illness the same way we look at physical
illness.
We're so,
it's so easy.
Paul Gil Martin just made this point
when he was on my podcast last week.
If you went up to somebody with diabetes
type one diabetes and you were like,
what the fuck dude?
Why don't you just think more positively
so that your pancreas makes insulin?
Like what's wrong with you?
Why can't you just make more insulin?
It's like they'd be like,
what are you talking about?
It's the same thing with depression.
People put the onus on you like they,
they look at it like
it's a disease of will,
but it's not.
It's a,
it's a biological illness and that's just
very hard for people to understand and
so what you end up doing is carrying
around a lot of guilt and shame and a lot
of feelings like,
I'm not good enough.
I can't will myself out of this
if I just think more positively.
It's not about that,
and I did that for years,
years.
You just deal with it and I destroyed.
Oh,
so many relationships.
The feeling of being a self,
the feeling that we call I,
the feeling of being an ego in the head
is what it feels like to be thinking
without knowing that you're thinking.
It's the,
it's the feeling of this next thought,
capturing consciousness.
So when you say that thoughts,
you are identical to thoughts.
So if you're thinking something
really fucked up like a,
I'm fat,
I'm a loser,
I'm always going to be a loser.
Like that is identical to who you are
because you are sort of framing yourself
in this thought,
these thoughts that you're
carrying around your mind there,
what's occupying your
consciousness and the,
if those thoughts are on the forefront
of your consciousness that they identify
you,
you are,
that you are those thoughts and
you are identical to that idea.
Yeah.
And their and their driving behavior
and they're driving emotion and they're
driving each subsequent train of thought.
So it's,
it's,
it's determining the,
the,
the future expressions of your
consciousness and your body as well.
Those guys,
I mean it's not easy if for example,
Brock was furious when Vince told him
that he wanted him to beat the undertaker
that day.
Like in real life like Betty was.
And you were there to see it.
No,
but I talked to somebody who was,
but he was honest with you.
It's not like they lie all day.
Every day.
Tony is going to talk to some people.
Let me tell you a little,
I'll tell you what.
Brock was actually mad.
He was really mad.
He read the script and
you just like bullshit.
I'm not picking up.
Fuck you.
Don't undertake undertaker.
Some of the guys that work,
unlike the technical side
for the UFC work for the WWE,
ARD,
Brock was crying.
That's what I heard.
That's went to the hospital
with the undertaker.
Cried so hard.
He dehydrated himself for that match.
They had to give him an IV
to replenish his teasing thought he
killed the undertaker from that concussion
was bad.
Bad.
It was real.
The concussions are real.
You can't,
I don't even buy it was a real concussion.
I probably faked a concussion.
Then dot.
Jt,
I'm not take her to the hospital.
He's got up Bobo and
even on the real booboo.
Folks,
if you don't take,
it's a real boob.
La,
show you the fucking band aid on it
for your own belief.
Pitching something at four year olds,
so booboo,
it is a booboo and needs up their day.
Honey,
there's no,
he's not even bleeding.
You don't need a bandaid bandaid.
Okay,
well bandaid make you feel better.
We'll get you a bandaid.
Did took the undertaker
and put a bandaid on him.
Tony Hinchcliffe in a gold
suit holding the script.
I can't believe it's our real poop.
He's jumping up and down in circles and
Vince Mcmahon is standing there shaking
his head.
Got Color of purple.
I'll fucking pent up with rage.
That's how I wrote it
out.
It's a booboo.
Look at the bandaid.
It's real.
It's a real bandaid.
Ladies and gentlemen,
if you doubt it.
What else do you like?
That sucks.
Um,
I was driving,
I live on the east side and I was driving,
I was riding on a TV show for a little
while and I was driving to work one
morning and I couldn't get to work because
there was so much traffic and I was
just like,
what the fuck is going on?
It's,
it's 9:45 AM on Hollywood boulevard.
Why is the show backed up?
And then I saw people like walking
around with these shirts on that said our
wounds are still open
and I feel like a real,
I know I'm an asshole before say this.
I thought it was some kind of record
released
and I was getting so mad.
I thought like a rapper,
like a release day is going on.
It was still open.
Our mouth,
I'll close is moving.
I rustled my toes
pretty,
my teeth is gold.
You're trying to buy my album,
but the shit's already sold out on
free style 2014 we won much love.
I've been trying to understand
this American phenomena
is southern Baptists and
one of the things that I think is the key
to this is that I think when they talk
about being born again,
originally baptism was just that.
I mean no,
you can get this through
DMT in five minutes,
but at the time of John The baptist,
you get it in five minutes
through being droned.
People were lining up on
the bank of the Jordan.
They go in,
he holds them under.
If he held him under just long enough,
you could actually induce
and near death experience.
New Life Review at the drowning
man sees his life pass before him,
hold them out of just long enough and
they'd have a near death experience almost
guaranteed.
I mean occasionally they might,
he might've done it too long,
but that was before litigation that
you might've lost four litigate.
Yeah.
Good theory actually.
And then you see they
come back and they said,
I've died.
I've seen the light.
I'd been born again.
I'm no longer afraid of death.
My life has been
transformed in five minutes.
And the baptists were the people who
revived baptism by total immersion in the
16th century and probably know in,
in America,
we don't hold the amount of that long
cause this is post litigation now.
But you know when,
when the Baptist first got going,
this idea of holding people
aren't as long enough.
All their language is the language
that relates to near death experiences.
And I don't think that to start with
baptism by total immersion was just
symbolic.
I think it was drowning.
Exactly.
It's a beautiful sensual ally.
And I've had to deny myself that central
ally for the last three years because I
abused it because we want to
spark up a joint right now.
I
want to dive in right now.
Of course,
the Gel,
you're like,
you're like the serpent
in the garden of Eden.
Sure.
You want yes.
You sure?
Why not?
I don't want to force you into anything.
You're not,
you're not forcing me.
An interesting mix went na na,
na,
na that.
I'm going to go,
I'm going to go live on Joe Rogan.
Is that bad?
No,
that's not bad.
That's the way to do it.
If you want to dive in,
we'll go.
A little baby hit.
So what I was getting into was,
um,
this,
this teller here,
American shit too.
That's
not that crappy.
Get in England.
That's made by American
scientists and botanists.
They all drive muscle
cars and they do steroids.
That's so familiar.
That's such a nice feeling.
But do they allow like
porn sites like in dorms?
Can kids get download porn?
Well,
I mean there's,
I mean,
Jamie sent me up to go to a site no more.
Well,
yeah,
I mean you don't,
but you could always just download
it right from like a torrent.
Well you could just Google
porn and it'll be right there.
Right?
That's true.
Yeah.
But I'm just wondering
Monday giving out tips,
guys,
what's your favorite
one?
The one behind,
you know
it's right there.
It is.
Right.
We'll know what to do it again to
start all over again with Noah.
Sam,
same deal.
And he also had all of those
animals to fuck to no one.
We probably couldn't fuck the animals
cause he's had a fuck his kids and make
sure it made more kids.
Am I going to make people get saved?
Those loads.
He was 500 years old.
I really felt that that should
have been the Russell Crowe movie.
Yes.
And just him fucking his kids.
You know what I mean?
Just two hours of Russell Crowe fucking
his daughter while the fucking rock
monster's guard over them.
Yeah.
I liked the Hollywood
executive with this guy.
Like make me one of
them kid fucking movies.
Get a Bible
lesson.
If they have a better explanation,
let them write the script.
Hire a couple of Jews,
maybe a kid fucking moving
the idea of speaking about anything,
anything and everything.
Uh,
I think it's detrimental to not be able
to talk and to have people that want to
shut other people up based
on their ideology or,
um,
anything that they're saying.
If you want to take someone
off the air of shut them up,
uh,
or,
or fire them from their job,
I think that's copping out and saying,
look,
I,
I can't logically argue or,
or intelligently argue.
So I just want them quiet.
I want them silence.
Don't they know that by hamstring you,
they fuck up their product and they
open up the door to the Internet.
Yeah.
Like the Internet.
It's right there.
It's the wolf at the door.
Oh,
it's right there.
Right there.
And really,
you know,
I was born deaf on one
side without a right or,
and,
uh,
in a family that wasn't very supportive.
And,
um,
I thought that success was going to be
the key to contentment and happiness.
And like a lot of other people thankfully
became successful only to find out
that didn't change anything.
And then the struggle becomes,
okay,
what's it gonna take to be happy?
The most I ever offered a sex worker was,
um,
10 grand.
She wasn't,
this is a,
this is some vampire shit.
This is like when
someone's not a sex worker.
Yeah.
It's like,
hey,
like,
not in the Asian guys don't
want to fuck you at all.
Like I have no desire to
fuck you and you're really,
you're
a Douche bag your crude.
And I go,
okay.
So since,
since I'm not denying any of that,
um,
so this is real money.
Like this isn't a joke.
Like,
you know,
I'm going to,
I'm going to turn you into a horror.
I'm sorry,
I'm going to turn,
you know,
sex worker.
Did you say that to her?
So she's doesn't believe me.
And then I take a picture,
I go,
I'm holding 10 grand right now.
And she goes,
fuck you.
You piece of shit.
Like you think you think
like you can buy me.
I go,
all right,
fine.
Whatever.
I don't think much about it.
She calls me two months later.
The text is,
is the offer still good?
I don't even,
I don't even know who the
girl is.
I go,
who is this and what?
What are you talking about?
She calls me and she goes,
you offered me tenure,
and I go,
no,
it's five grand now.
And she goes,
you piece?
I go,
I offered you 10 grand
when I was horniest.
Then I was like,
I was playing a game and
I wanted it that bad.
I'm like,
when you said no,
it's five grand.
What'd she say that she said,
go fuck yourself.
Then she didn't have no,
then she called me back and then she came
and she fucked me and then she didn't
take the money and she left
and I thought she forgot.
I said,
hey,
you didn't take the money
and still on the thing.
She said,
go fuck yourself.
And then we have a weird,
and we still fuck now we
have a weird relationship.
The record at its core is about love.
You know,
being like this one universal truth.
You get a lot of people look to religion.
A lot of people look to drugs and I'm
not saying you can't get really spiritual
experiences from all of those things,
but I think love at the end of the day
is the one thing that really I've ever
found forced me to want to wake up and
really try to be a better human being
every day.
You know?
So that was the main point of the album
and the turtles thing was just kind of,
it's a way of saying if you get into an
argument with somebody and you realize
it's just pointless and
you're going back and forth,
it's turtles all the way down because
like nobody really knows shit,
you know?
And we're all just trying
to not kill each other.
So I don't know,
I decided it would make
a good country song.
Didn't you have like plans on being some
sort of a marine biologist or something
at some point?
Yeah,
I tell people that story
because this is funny.
On Twitter.
I found this rock,
my daughter found this rock on the
beach in Santa Barbara and how all these
holes in it and we're trying to figure
out what the fuck it was was an asteroid
or something.
I put on Twitter.
I go,
what's this rock Joe fucking Perry is
the first guy to answer me on Twitter and
tells me it's a see stone.
Like these animals had to like burrowed
into this stone and create a little
homes really well.
Um,
well anyway,
uh,
oh,
here's a great story.
They landed a fucking comment.
They landed on a comet and uh,
the guy who landed on the comet was
wearing a shirt that had all these photos.
Are these drawings of women on it?
Yeah.
Look at this.
I don't care if you landed.
It's
fucking beautiful.
I should hire like a real shower.
Expensive
tailor to make me an awesome suit of that.
Yeah.
The jacket and the pants with a vast,
it ties the whole thing.
Oh,
that would be awesome.
They have the inside of the vest,
like the ones that UFC made me,
they have like little skull and crossbones
and the sat and we could have it all
little dicks,
little ticks and some,
and even there was a
recent report on Hitler.
Hitler himself was on uh,
a litany of medication
and one of them was math.
They were giving a math.
They would give,
do people back down,
fault him for that dude.
The amount of energy that that
guy put out during his speeches,
he needed something to level off.
Forget about,
forget about the screaming and yelling.
Just sitting that still
waiting for the right moment.
Building them into that,
that frenzy.
Do you ever watch that Michael Jackson
documentary right before he died,
when he drove,
just freeze after he did a dance move.
Let it simmer,
let it simmer.
That's Hitler ship sitting
in that fucking chair.
Just getting them crazy.
Just wanting to hear
or see the next thing.
What's he going to do?
It's timing.
Is it fucking timing the
balls to do that on stage?
The Michael Jackson Hitler simmer moment.
You would have to.
We got to do that tonight
at the comedy still.
Alright.
We go.
Okay.
We've got to have this.
You've got to have a dude.
If we had some of the technology,
I could be in your ear telling me you
had to keep a straight face after a
punchline.
As you're looking down
at some fucked up pose,
I'm just going to let it simmer.
Let it simmer,
let it simmer and release.
So my dad was great.
Yeah,
I had a bird,
had bird feeders out I bought recently
and they found out about it and now they
won't leave my house alone.
They're there like every day.
You amazing.
That's cool dude.
That's pretty dope.
Yeah.
They're loud too loud that
they're annoying as fuck.
No,
you didn't hear flows on put that will
let them into your spiritual compass.
How is it that it's illegal if
you don't clean up after your dog,
but you're allowed to just have
your fucking horse shit everywhere.
Empty.
It's giant asshole.
1200 pound body of stewed grasses.
I'm sorry.
Is this cobblestone?
This is a dirt road.
You farmer.
Fuck.
Pick up after that donkey.
Your donkey.
Just Shit.
All of my Prius
dog,
he's not that green.
This is contributing to global warming.
Donkey was dirty ass.
All Brian said he didn't
like Paris in his name.
He's in bed with the chicken
mark.
Like I never said anybody.
I only done this before.
Oh my God.
Of course.
I always work on
bringing the fucking
parents into the courthouse.
We would now like to call
a prosecution witness.
The Burbank Paris.
I've never seen this before.
No.
Roofie what are you talking about are,
you
know,
two heads is fine.
I take two hits all the time
and I drive an ingrown hair.
You know,
all you need to do is you need
to do shit with that stuff.
Kills everything.
It'll tell ah,
Eddie and that worked out at 24 hour
fitness and there's this dude who was the
manager there.
It was a cool guy.
We just talked to them and uh,
they had sent him over from
the Santa Monica Place.
He was like a real personable,
real friendly guy.
Like he,
you know,
real easy to like.
And so,
uh,
the Santa Monica police brought him in
because they needed to get that place
cleaned out because he had
basically become just a fuck house.
Yeah,
the close the shower hose them down.
Everyone that'd be common condos.
But my buddy ended up working,
that's how I found out I,
but I ended up working at the same place
and they used to have to trap nudes,
gay dudes that were fucking
in the sauna and stuff.
And
I told the cop came cause it was
right next to a police station.
How people die,
Bro.
Don't trap me in the Sauna.
Make me fuck.
I will do it.
Are you ready?
You Ready?
You better let me out of here,
man.